Now you,
you're ever stopped?
Yeah.
Your first team all fanny pack.
Damn.
No deep to labs going off up and slammed the shit out of him.
Yeah.
No,
he's good man.
Nor Dean's very good.
I never stopped with the fanny pack.
No,
you just ride through it even.
Yeah.
People are like to chose fanny pack and like,
I know man.
It's his thing.
There's a shit on.
Yeah.
I saw the shit out of him.
I'm always out of stock.
My boy wants one bad hire.
I made.com we were at Disneyland.
Are we close to MMA and the Olympics?
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
They're working on it.
Yeah,
they're trying.
Can you imagine that?
Well,
it would be.
I can't imagine.
It would be amazing now with Russia,
just when all the belts are,
they would about,
we had some chickens,
man fucking situation.
I mean,
Russia would be tough,
man.
It,
it really depends entirely on drug testing,
but they'll figure it out.
I mean,
Russians when it comes,
you know,
boxed and combat sports.
Russia is really pretty fucking Dagestan be considered Russia.
But the thing is though is what I was putting it under the same banner.
But the thing is,
what would happen is if it did become huge in the Olympics,
then people would realize like,
you know how guys like Floyd Mayweather and so many different professional
boxers got their start as Olympic gold medalist and then went on to become these
huge superstars in boxing.
Lama Chenko is another good example.
When you have a real great amateur background,
people get super amped up.
Gopro,
Andre Ward.
Yeah.
Anthony.
Joshua.
Yup.
You get super amped up about seeing those guys go pro in America.
It's a little different though for the reason when it comes to boxing.
Yeah.
Because we liked the other can we used to with mark Breland remember those days
with Tyrrell pigs?
We used to love it.
Yeah.
We used to love it when a guy was a Olympic gold medal.
Pernell Whitaker,
you know,
uh,
Ray Mercer [inaudible] Andre Ward.
But it's still,
you know,
and he look at this leg lock
Deontay wilder has a bronze medal.
This was shamed because he started sad,
very boxed in like total one.
Oh Shit.
Anytime you hit them double outside ashes and MMA,
they're risky.